[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to the
Radcliffe Institute.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm the Dean of the
Radcliffe Institute
and I'm delighted you're here.
We're in for a very
exciting conversation
today between feminist, artist,
activist, and educator, Judy
Chicago, and historian,
Jane Gerhard,
which will be moderated by
Nancy Cott, the Pforzheimer
Foundation Director of
the Schlesinger Library
and the Jonathan Trumbull
Professor of American History
here at Harvard.
I want to express my
thanks to Nancy Cott,
as well as to Marilyn
Dunn, who is the Executive
Director of the library
who has really spearheaded
this tribute to Judy Chicago,
also to Exhibition Coordinator
Bruce Williams, and
to the entire library
staff for planning both the
exhibition and this program
today to celebrate one of
our most precious manuscript
collections, the "Papers
of Judy Chicago."
These papers not only shed
light on Judy Chicago's
well-known and ambitious
Dinner Party now
on permanent display
in the Brooklyn Museum,
but they reveal much more
about her development
as a visual and a
performance artist,
about her collaborations with
other artists and activists,
and about her feminist
approach to teaching
aimed at helping women fully
express their creativity.
Before we hear
from Judy and Jane,
we're going to begin in an
unusual but very appropriate
way given today's guest with
a performance piece directed
by Harvard College
junior Lelaina Vogel.
Lelaina will be joined on
stage by junior Rachel Gibeon
and sophomore's [? Alana ?]
Bach, Alice Berensen,
and Danielle [? Lasard. ?]
Lelaina's piece is inspired
by the teaching techniques
Judy devised when she started
the very first feminist art
program in the United States
at Fresno State in 1970.
And then she
developed it further
when she moved to the California
Institute of the Arts in 1972.
There, she began collaborating
with fellow artist and faculty
member Miriam Shapiro, which
led to the creation of Woman
House, a feminist exhibition
and performance space fashioned
from an abandoned mansion.
Both Judy and her
students exhibited
several important
pieces there that helped
define feminist art.
So it's fitting today
that our program
will start with a
performance conceived
by an undergraduate student at
Harvard who has been inspired
by the way Judy Chicago's
teaching encourages
women's creativity.
Lelaina's piece titled
Performing the Archive
is meant to connect
the library's
exhibit with the conversation
we will soon witness.
I'm also delighted that
Lelaina's performance piece
will launch our program today,
because it embodies much
of what we are trying to
accomplish here at Radcliffe,
integrating the arts with
other kinds of knowledge,
and seeking ways of involving
students in our Institute
for Advanced Study.
One of the ways that dozens
of Harvard College students
participate in the
life of the Institute
is to work closely with many
of the Institute's Annual 50
Fellows on their scholarly
and creative projects as what
we call Radcliffe
Research Partners.
This in fact, is how the Lelaina
found her way to the Institute
last year when she became an
actor in artist and fellow
David Levine's
performance piece which
was called Character Analysis.
Through that project, Lelaina
met library staff member Bruce
Williams who coordinates
exhibitions at the library.
And when Bruce hatched the idea
of commissioning a performance
piece based on Judy's papers
to accompany the exhibition,
he immediately
thought of Lelaina.
So now we are in for a very
special treat and a unique way
to pay tribute to Judy Chicago's
lasting influence on the arts
as we observe how her approach
to fostering women's creativity
is being interpreted by the next
generation of women artists.
So without further ado, I am
delighted to present to you
the debut of
Performing the Archive.
Thank you all.
That was a great
beginning for what
I hope is going to be a very
exciting and unique afternoon.
We have here, as
you know, we have
Judy Chicago on the year
of her 75th birthday
which we are celebrating
and very happy to spotlight,
and her most recent
historian Jane Gerhard.
Judy Chicago is somebody
I'm delighted to honor.
She is one of the
most important,
innovative, and productive
American artists
of her generation.
She is one of the best
known living artists,
but she has never ceased
to be controversial.
And in getting to today, she
has never found her path easy
because she is an
iconoclast and path breaker.
By 1970, she made it very
clear that she intended
to create art arising from
a woman's subjectivity,
to create art from
women's experiences,
and to represent the hidden
parts of women's bodies
that Western art had avoided
and evaded even while it made,
as she wrote, I quote her, "the
female body, the repository
of so many emotions."
Representations of women
had been omnipresent
in Western art, but Judy
Chicago and other voices
for women's liberation at the
time insisted on the limits
on the objectification
in those representations.
Along with others
of her generation,
Judy Chicago insisted
upon intellectual and
epistemological
transformation to show women
as feeling subjects.
Though the results shocked
viewers, horrified many,
in fact, she had
a reparative aim
along with a disruptive one.
She aimed to repair,
and I quote her,
"the damage done to
our perceptual powers
by the absence of images
of female reality."
Now, when I think
of Judy Chicago,
I think of several
elements, clarity of vision,
imagination, conviction,
and especially
extraordinary courage.
And I want to give
a few examples
of the courageous things she did
in the beginning of her career
when it was hardest,
the installation
called the menstruation bathroom
in Women House in Los Angeles.
This was a revolutionary
instance of her gutsiness.
As was the preceding
photo lithograph
called Red Flag which
showed a woman's hand
pulling a bloody tampon out
of her vagina.
I think I'm on safe ground
in saying that no one before
had even considered making
a bloody tampon a subject
for art.
Then there was the justly
famous Dinner Party,
which is now in a magnificent
installation in the Brooklyn
Museum at the Elizabeth Sackler
Center for Feminist Art,
but that happened
only seven years ago.
And for many years,
official museums
wouldn't show the Dinner Party.
It gathered its huge notoriety
and its huge audiences
from showings in venues
such as the Boston
Cyclorama in the south end where
I remember seeing it in 1980.
And a brochure from
that time, a brochure
you can see in the exhibit,
includes a quotation from Judy
that perfectly
illustrates how her work--
certainly her work in
that installation--
dovetails perfectly with the
mission of the Schlesinger
Library.
And I quote her, "We can know
ourselves and our capacities
by seeing that other
women have been strong.
To reclaim our past
and insist that it
become a part of
human history is
the task that lies before us."
Then following the
Dinner Party, Judy
inaugurated The Birth
Project to remedy
what she saw as an iconagraphic
void in Western art,
that there were hardly any
representations of birth,
at least from a
female point of view.
Now, in these three things
that I have mentioned,
I think her work might
be denominated, if you'll
allow me, honoring the cunt.
Judy made viewers stare
straight on at the female vulva,
the womb, the
clitoris, the vagina
in a politics of recognition
about as iconoclast
as one could be.
Yet at the same
time, in the 1980s,
she began to work on
representing the male body
and emotions in her
project called Power Play.
And in the next decade, she
moved to her Holocaust Project.
Was the Holocaust too
extreme to display in art?
Well, to Judy Chicago,
no human experience,
whether it was generative or
destructive was too extreme.
Tapestry became the
medium for that project
because, as she
noted, and I quote,
"The Holocaust grew
out of the very fabric
of Western civilization."
By that time, tapestry
was no stranger to her.
The diversity of types
of projects she has done
and of materials she has used
is another astonishing thing
about her oeuvre--
painting, performance--
as we saw here--
photography, embroidery,
weaving, tapestry,
ceramics, using wood, metal,
porcelain, ivory, oil,
acrylic, silk, and in
some of her early work
dry ice and fireworks.
I wonder how many artists
have become or tried
to become licensed
pyrotechnicians as Judy did?
Today, we're going to hear about
another genre of her creativity
and productivity
in art education.
She began offering what must be
called feminist art education
as early as 1969 as Liz Cohen
mentioned, and has continued
to do so in one form or
another until the present day.
Though for most of
the past 40 years,
not within academic
institutions,
but rather in her
collaborative art
projects which always
drew in volunteers.
During the early
2000s, though, she
taught six semester-long
stints in six
different academic
institutions, universities.
And that is the
background against which
we should place
her new book, which
is called Institutional Time;
a Critique of Studio Art
Education.
As someone who favors
paradoxical and double meaning
titles, I love this
title, Institutional Time.
To me, it conjures
up the Goffman notion
of the total institution, it
connotes "doing time" in jail.
Simultaneously, it
suggests that institutions
have their own regime
or schedule that
implicitly differs from human
scale time or task orientation.
And it also suggests
to me that Judy
thought it was about time
that she should take up
the burden of addressing
directly studio art
education, since her own
discomfort with and rebellion
against the status
quo in art started
during her own
education at UCLA where
she got a master's degree
in painting and sculpture
in the '60s.
We have the special treat today
of a dialogue with both Judy
Chicago and her most recent
historian Jane Gerhard.
Jane-- I'm going to call both
women by their first names,
something I would not normally
do and might normally regard
as somewhat disrespectful--
but it's hard to address Judy
Chicago as anything but Judy.
So I have to do
the same with Jane.
Jane's first book also has
a wonderfully double meaning
title, Desiring Revolution.
And it was what made her known
as a historian of 20th century
feminism.
It examines the sexual
thought of 1970s feminists.
And it traces why and how the
women's movement of the 1960s
and '70s took up the
issue of sexual liberation
for themselves.
Now, she has just published
a new book called The Dinner
Party; Judy Chicago and the
Power of Popular Feminism,
which is a cultural
history of the phenomenon
that Judy's work inspired.
And Jane argues that Judy's
work not only participated in,
but shaped larger debates about
feminism in the 1980s and '90s,
the so-called
post-feminist years.
And further, she thinks that
looking at the reception
and influence of Judy's
work can indicate
that feminism was a broader
phenomenon than historians
have usually claimed.
That it has to be
seen to include
culture and consumption
and an investment
in personal transformation.
So we'll hear more about her
views and her own reactions
to Judy's work today.
Now let me invite them both
to come up on the stage.
And the way we are
going to proceed
is that I am going to ask each
of them several questions.
But I want to tell you, the
audience, that these questions
are questions that came from
the other person I'm not
questioning.
In other words, the questions
I'm going to ask Judy
came from Jane, and vice versa.
And after each of them answers
the questions I will raise,
then there will be
some time for them
to perhaps dialogue a
little between themselves
if they would like to,
and we'll then open it up
to you, the audience.
So let's begin.
First, I'm going to
question Jane Gerhard
and ask her the obvious
question, how did you
come to write The Dinner Party?
I was interested
in finding some way
to think about '70s feminism
outside of a social movement
framework.
You know, how to think
about the impact of feminism
for people who weren't in
political organizations.
And The Dinner Party was
a perfect object for that,
because you could see--
you could see it move forward
in time across various decades
with its feminist DNA intact.
And you could trace
the reactions to it.
So it became like this
perfect object to move--
to sort of chart the changes
in feminist thinking,
the reception of the ideas
of feminism over time,
instead of thinking of
feminism as a static,
you know, a static set of ideas.
I mean, the power of
feminism has always
been that it touches
people's lives,
as well as changes laws
or changes institutions.
And I wanted some kind of way
in to that process, something
that was rigorous, like I
could do an archival study of,
but that I could see how
people changed in encountering
the ideas of feminism.
And Judy's archive
is so interesting
because there are letters from
viewers, there are letters
from, or documents
written by people
who worked on the project.
So there was a lot of more
ordinary voices in the archive
than you would find in other--
for other objects.
You know, it was kind of a
gold mine on that front that
could really get at how people
saw the ideas that Judy was
laying out through the arts.
And so that made it a very
exciting kind of test object,
an object to see how ideas of
feminism have moved forward.
I got started on the project
after Boot Camp in Women's
History here in this building
that you had run in 2006,
I believe.
And I was imagining
that I was going to do
a chapter on The Dinner Party.
And then I went
over to the archives
and saw just the extent of
them and my mind was blown.
And I was like, oh, my god.
This is really
where I need to sit.
This is really where
there's so much,
there's so many stories here
that aren't in our records.
And there's a great
opportunity to really get
to think about material
culture in an interesting way.
Can you say a little bit more
about differences in reaction
or versions of feminist reaction
after, say, the late '80s
and into the '90s as compared to
what the initial reactions were
in the '70s?
Yeah.
Clearly had
controversies going on
attached to it still in 1990.
But my argument in
the book is really
that, as we got
farther away from 1979,
1980, some of the controversy
begins to die down.
So there's sort of a
new audience by 1990.
I think its status as history,
as we got farther away
from the '70s Feminist
Movement ended up
sort of making it more possible
to see it on its own terms
and being less controversial.
It was no longer
the battleground
for a certain high-pitched
feminist battle going
on about how to
represent feminism,
you know, what
kind of ambassador
should this art be
for the movements?
You know, the
movement had really
dissipated in a lot
of important ways.
It didn't end, but the social
movement piece of it had
definitely died
down by mid-'80s.
And so I think it became
possible to view it
in a new light.
And view it as a representative
of a certain moment
in feminism, which I
think paved the ground
to let it become canonized as it
has in at the Brooklyn Museum.
What about, what was
your own response
to seeing The Dinner Party?
And had you seen it already
when you began work on the book?
No.
No, I had heard about it in
my Women's Studies classes
and found only the critique
of The Dinner Party
as being essentialist.
And you know, even in
my first book, that's
the kind of reading I offered,
that this was an example
of feminist essentialism.
So when I went and saw
it, when it finally opened
in Brooklyn in 2007--
you know, it had been
very hard to see.
I was a child in 1980.
I did not get to see it
in Boston or in Chicago
and there was no opportunity
for me to have seen it.
So when I finally did
get to see it in 2007,
I was really struck
by the force of it,
the kind of emotional
power that it held.
It was visually arresting.
By then I had--
I have a PhD in Women's
History so I really
appreciated the intellectual
underpinnings of the piece.
But I was caught off guard by
the emotional impact of it, the
seeing it all together.
And then that really
kind of stuck in my mind.
So when I was looking
for a project,
that's why I initially thought,
a chapter on The Dinner Party.
It is a fabulous installation
that really shows off
the piece magnificently.
And in order to track the
changing views of the piece
and of feminism, did you also
do interviews with people?
Yes.
I predominantly
used the archive,
but I wanted to make sure I was
reading the archival evidence
correctly, so I
interviewed people--
I'd say about 15 people.
I interviewed Judy twice.
But that was well after I
had gotten very embedded
into the archive, that was a
year or so into the archive
before I wanted to check
in with other people who
had worked on it.
For example, when I found
a specific document,
it was about the decision to
open the studio to volunteers
in 1977.
And I hadn't heard anything
about how the mechanism worked
to get people into the studio.
And it seemed to me
that they were actually
opening the studio for
a number of reasons.
One was certainly to get
help to finish the piece.
But part of it was also to get--
to build audience
interest, to build--
to build-- sell a
certain kind of--
to offer a certain kind
of feminist experience
to other people in the area.
You know, you could
volunteer to come work
at the studio for a month,
three months, whatever.
So I didn't really know how to--
I really needed to
do research on that.
So that's when I started to
get in touch with more people
more regularly, just so I
made sure I really understood
what this document meant.
So it's predominantly archival.
But the people you contacted
were not simply viewers.
They were people who
had been involved
in created the project.
People who were
active in the project.
And did Judy, once you met
her and interviewed her,
influence the book
it all or play a part
in what you eventually wrote?
I have to say, I was pretty
clear about what was going on.
And Judy confirmed
things for me.
She didn't change the story,
she gave me more information.
She supplemented with a couple
of extra financial documents
that weren't in the archive yet.
But she didn't imprint the
story that I had already
gotten set in my mind.
She really just answered
my questions and let go.
Great, thank you.
Thank you so much, Jane.
Now, I'm going to move to
some questions for Judy.
Since the beginning, of course,
of your career, Judy, you--
or almost the very beginning,
you used the term feminist art.
I noticed that in
one of the documents
we have in the exhibit you
have on it, you write on it,
in addition to the
representations
and forms on it, you
say, "Feminist art
is all the stages of a woman
giving birth to herself."
But that was written
quite a while ago,
and I wondered how you
define feminist art now,
particularly since the book is
about feminist art education?
And so tell us
about how you define
both of those things, feminist
art and feminist art education.
I often say that in the '70s
we kind of cast the discourse
incorrectly, because we cast
it entirely around gender.
And actually, feminism
is more about values.
And you don't have to be
a woman to be a feminist.
One of the problems with having
cast the discourse entirely
around gender is
that we made friends
with people who
weren't our friends,
and made enemies of people who
could have been our friends.
For example, my husband, Donald
Woodman, the photographer,
he was at MIT in the '70s at the
height of the Women's Movement
here.
And when he was a returning
graduate at the University
of Houston--
I mean, he was a
pretty radical guy
and he had value is
very similar to my own.
When he was in the
University of Houston,
he was approached by a group
that wanted to bring The Dinner
Party to Houston--
because he's very
handy, and they
needed a preparetor, and a team
to install The Dinner Party.
And at some point he was
told he couldn't participate
because of his gender.
I always say, he had to marry
me to install The Dinner Party.
But anyway, so because
my definition was so
focused on gender in the '70s,
my definition of a feminist art
was similarly focused.
Now that I have expanded
my concept of feminism,
I've also expanded my
concept of feminist art.
And that is, my
concept of feminism
underwent the kind of
expansion that took place
as a result of the '80s
critique of the universalizing
of the term woman.
And then when Donald and
I worked on The Holocaust
Project, I really began
to see gender oppression
as part of a whole global
structure of injustice
and oppression
that, in my values,
would be overturned through
a feminist revolution.
And so what does that
mean about feminist art?
It means that feminist art
is grounded in a challenge
to the prevailing value
structure of our world.
And can men make feminist art?
Yes.
Actually, Catherine
Morris, the curator
at the Sackler Center at
the Brooklyn Museum kind of
answered that question
without raising it directly
by doing an exhibition
by a male artist who
was working on the subject
of Mary Wollstonecraft.
So, yes, men can
make feminist art.
In terms of feminist
art education, you know,
when I went back to
teaching in 1999,
one of the things I was
interested in discovering
was whether my pedagogical
principles could also
be applied to men.
And so that was
interesting for me,
and interesting when Donald
and I started team teaching.
And in fact, when I was at the
University of North Carolina,
Chapel Hill, which was the first
time I was teaching a really
mixed gender class, 50/50,
some of the male students
actually seemed to benefit
more than the female students
from my pedagogy, because some
of the women were resistant.
They were in thrall
to a different set
of values about art
that had been promoted,
that is promoted by the
male-centered art world.
And so that presented me
with a certain quandary
about how, since I'm so
committed to women's education,
how do I feel about
the idea that it would
be men who would benefit more?
I don't have the answer to
that, but it was definitely
a question that
was raised for me.
About your experiences
of teaching students,
you've done it in many different
ways for many decades now.
And are the students
you've taught--
obviously you just
mentioned now there
are men as well as women--
but in other ways, in
terms of their values,
their expectations,
do you see changes
that are worth
commenting on in terms
of the students' outlooks?
It was interesting,
because Jane was talking
about doing interviews--
because Institutional Time is
both a print book and it
will also be an e-book.
I did something I had never
done before, which was--
and I did it also for the
new Dinner Party book--
I did interviews
for the e-books.
And I interviewed some of the
my former students and some--
like for example,
I interviewed--
One of the things
that was really great
about the interviews
is that I didn't really
tell them that much about what
I had dealt with in the book.
And I'd be sitting
there interviewing them,
for example, Nancy Yodelman
who was one of the, quote,
"Fresno" girls, you know--
they all say, "oh, Judy,
we're all in our 50s or 60s."
And I'm like, "well, you'll
always be the girls to me."
But anyway, I was sitting
there interviewing her.
And one of my points in
the book is that university
studio art education
is inherently
biased against women.
So Nancy's telling
this story about when
she was at Fresno State
before she took my class
and how she makes sculpture.
She does, she casts dresses
in bronze and other materials.
But she said, I didn't
want to have anything
to do with the
sculpture department.
Why, I say?
She says, because I didn't
want to make a plaster cube.
So I'm talking in the
book about the fact
that there's this
assumption, like when--
you know, I don't if it
has changed that much
since when I was a
student-- but like everyone
is going to build
something with a 4 by 4.
I had no idea what a 4 by 4 was.
I never used a power saw.
I mean I didn't know how to
build anything with a 4 by 4.
And so here she is talking about
exactly the same thing, right?
Or in another
chapter I interviewed
a boy, very talented boy who
was in the project Donald
and I did at Western Kentucky
University in Bowling Green,
where we revisited the
subject of the home
30 years after Woman House with
both male and female students
in a project called
At Home in Kentucky.
And in the chapter called
Beyond the Diploma,
I talk about what young
artists, young graduates face
when they get out
of graduate school,
the kind of shock when they
begin to understand as, I quote
at the beginning of the
book, an MFA student who
wrote one of the few books on
university study art education.
It's quite shocking
how little there
is in contrast to how much
there is on K-12, for example.
Anyway, one book is a
book called Art Subjects;
Making Artists in the American
University by Howard Singerman.
And in there, he went to
one of the top art schools.
He either went to Cal Arts
or UCLA, he never said.
And he said, "Although I hold
a master of Fine Arts degree
in sculpture, I do not
have the traditional skills
of the sculptor.
I cannot carve or cast
or weld or model in clay.
Why not?"
In other words, he may know how
to talk about being an artist,
but he cannot actually make
art because of the de-skilling
of studio art education.
So you know it was like this
boy who was in the Kentucky
program, when I was talking
about how difficult it
is for young artists.
You know, when I got out of
graduate school I was in LA,
it was very cheap to live.
My first studio I shared
with two other artists.
We had a 5,000
square foot studio.
We paid $75 a month together.
But that's completely changed.
These young people get
out with big debts,
they have no ability--
you know there's only
two systems for making
money as an artist,
either the gallery system
or the university system,
and most of them have
to get full-time jobs.
And so I was
interviewing Josh Edwards
who was a really gifted boy.
And he now runs the
whole exhibition program
for the new museum in New York.
And he said, I feel
so lucky that I
didn't have such a burning
desire to make my own art.
I'm perfectly happy
installing other people's art,
he said, because all my
friends are miserable.
They came out of school,
they're $100,000 in debt,
they have to get
a full-time job.
They have no time to make art.
They're just miserable.
And I'm like, oh,
where did I say
that in the book
about this poor kid?
So it was really interesting
having the opportunity
to see enacted a
lot of the points
that I was making in the book.
Well, on that, I know
I've heard other-wheres
that the only way a young artist
can make it at all these days
is by getting an MFA.
Whereas, that wasn't
always the case.
That is, that they will never
get into the gallery scene
if they don't make the
connections of getting an MFA.
An MFA?
You don't need an MFA
to get into a gallery.
In fact--
You don't think that's accurate?
Because where I
read this critique,
the person was lamenting
that there was just
a complete channeling
in that direction.
And otherwise, if
you were just really
talented and struck
out on your own--
If you are in the MFA program at
Yale or at Cal Arts or at UCLA
or any of the top schools in
the country, the Chicago Art
Institute, you are in a network.
Yeah.
And it is the network
that helps you.
It is not the MFA.
Oh, well that's
exactly what I meant.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
If you get an MFA,
they don't have
an MFA program at Western
Kentucky, but if they did
it would not help you.
Yeah.
And in fact-- not
getting in the network.
And in fact, a lot
of artists do not
say they have teaching jobs.
It actually-- I mean I quote
from a lot of-- from literature
that says, it kind of undermines
your cred as an artist
if you're teaching.
OK?
So there's a real
double standard.
Because a lot of--
you know, you don't
have any health benefits
if you don't have a job.
And you know that's how I
lived for most of my life.
But it was easier when I
was younger, way easier.
And also the MFA programs
were not feeder schools
for the art industry.
Right.
I think that's the nature
of the critique I read.
And it was more about
these elite schools
that compose the network.
And the complaint was that
if you're not in that--
Oh, yeah, that's
absolutely true.
But you know, you have to
realize at any given moment,
there are 40,000
young artists looking
for galleries in New York,
and the same number in London.
There are 10,000 MFAs
who are graduated
every year around the world
into a tiny distribution system.
That many?
Yes.
That is really something.
And now, there's
a whole new thing,
which is the idea of introducing
the PhD program in studio
art, which is guaranteed to
give us even more academic art
than we already have.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, on that
matter, you, of course,
started by founding an
alternative institution, Woman
House.
No, well, Women House
was an art project.
The only alternative
institution I founded
was the Woman's Building.
The Woman's Building, right,
with Sheila de Bretteville.
Yeah.
But my question was not
about those early projects,
it was more the general
point that your book
deals with university education
in studio art programs.
It doesn't say, let's do a
different model altogether.
Let's have something outside
the existing academia.
Can you tell us more about
why you decided to do that,
to take that tactic?
Well, in the '70s when we
started creating alternatives,
all women shows, and the
Woman's Building, Woman House,
Woman Space, the Women's
Art Journal, I mean,
I don't think that I seriously
thought we were going to be
able to reconstruct the entire
institutional structure of--
build an alternative structure
that would be viable enough
to compete with the existing
institutional structures
around the world that evolved
over decades, decades,
centuries, generations,
centuries, right?
What we were trying to do
was develop a strategy that
would bring women
into visibility,
would challenge the restrictions
and the exclusion of women.
But now, I am sick to
death of women shows,
because even now-- because
if what we wanted to do
was change the percentages
in the institutions, yeah,
we changed at the margins.
I mean, there's
just definitely--
it would be ridiculous
not to acknowledge
that there's been a
considerable amount of change.
Young women and artists
of color can be themselves
in ways that was impossible
when I was young.
There are many more women
and artists of color showing.
But you have to look
inside the statistics,
because mostly they're showing
in regional galleries, smaller
galleries, university museums.
And we were just in Washington
and in The Washington Post
on Sunday there was a huge
article about women directors
in the Washington area.
Fortunately Johnnetta
Cole was one of them.
And Johnnetta Cole, who I
got a honorary doctorate with
at the same time as Smith, and
we fell madly in love with each
other-- me and my husband,
her and her husband--
she is so smart.
And she's like, yeah, but if
you look at all the museums
that have budgets
over $200 million,
there's hardly one
woman running them.
And there are only five
women museum directors
of color in the entire country.
I'm like go, Johnnetta.
Because the way in which
our history is controlled--
and that's what I was
always interested in.
I was always interested
in making a contribution
to art history and changing
history and art history.
The way art history
is controlled
through solo
publications, monographs,
permanent collections
in the major museums,
and major exhibitions.
So you know, this celebration
of my 75th birthday--
I'll take the last one
first-- is very interesting,
because it's
basically an end run
around institutional resistance.
Because there is not a
major museum in the world
that would accord enough
space for a real retrospective
of my work.
Like last summer, Jim
Turrell, who I came up with,
was given 92,000 square
feet of museum space
in three museums around
the country simultaneously.
Never would a woman artist in my
generation get that much space.
And I could use it.
You know how much
room my archive
takes up here at the
Schlesinger, right?
I mean that's just my papers.
That's just the spin-off
from my production, right?
Yeah.
OK.
So the second is
museum collections.
I'm not in the Tate
Modern, I'm not
in the Museum of Modern
Art, I'm not in the Whitney,
I've never been in Whitney
Annual, I'm not in the Met,
I'm not in any of
the major museums.
I'm not in the Pompidou.
They have the Woman House
film at the Pompidou,
and they don't own
anything of mine, OK?
The percentage of women
in major collections
is between 3% and
5% around the world.
And in terms of solo
publications, in the 1970s,
1.7% of solo publications
were devoted to women.
We are now 40 years
later and the percentage
is an astounding 2.5%.
So you know, why am I
talking about calling
for a national dialogue
to examine the kind of art
education that's going on?
Because, in the end
of the 19th century--
I mean you know this here
at Harvard or at Cambridge--
at the end of the 19th century
when women first managed
to get into higher
education, they
came into an entirely
male-centered curriculum.
And yeah, we've added
women's studies courses.
Yeah, we've added
feminist theory.
But studying Susan
B. Anthony is still
not part of every Western
Civilization class
that everybody, every boy
and every girl has to study.
Why not?
She changed the face
of a nation, OK?
Same thing in art education.
Art education-- women
were brought in,
expected to know
what a 4 by 4 was,
expected to paint
from the female model
when they finally could
get academic training
and paint from the nude,
without any thought about what
does that do to your psyche.
Here you are a woman artist,
painting a nude female.
Everybody else is
dressed and she's naked.
From what point of view
should I look at her?
Am I the model, or
am I the artist?
And do I have the same
level of privilege?
Obviously not, from
the statistics.
So now, as far as
I'm concerned, we
should get 50% of the
space in all institutions.
That is what our
mandate has to be.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, so much.
I have more questions.
But I can tell from the
clapping that the audience is
eager to participate in this.
And I want to open
it up to them.
But let me first say, do have
a question you want to ask Judy
while we're here on stage?
I'd love to hear what
the audience has to say.
Do you want to ask Jane
something about her book
that you haven't
been able to ask yet?
I mean, I've had--
this is the forth dialogue
that Jane and I have had.
But the thing is is that,
before the first two
were just about her book.
I love her book.
I think, I mean, somebody
asked us at NMWA--
why do you call it "nemwa?"
Because the National
Museum of Women in the Arts
is too long to
say all the time--
asked about the
history that she tells
and how long it took
for The Dinner Party
to be permanently housed,
and all the myths that
surrounded The Dinner
Party, some of them
very personally painful to me.
And I said that a
long time ago, I
put my faith in history
and in art history.
It just took a really long time
for things to get sorted out.
And Jane sorted them out, in
terms of The Dinner Party.
And it's a great
read, lively, funny.
Perfect.
Yes.
Well, we have a microphone
here in the center
of the aisle and anyone who
would like to ask a question,
please step up to the mic.
I'm Ann [? Broughty, ?]
and I grew up
in LA when you were
making all kinds
of glorious trouble in town.
And it was a really vivid part
of being a teenager in LA.
I never went, myself,
to the Women's Building
or to Santa Monica to
work on The Dinner Party,
but it was so much a
part of what people were
talking about and experiencing.
It's really hard, as a
historian and a teacher,
to recapture for students
what the women's only spaces
of the 1970s meant in the kind
of revolutionary iconoclasm
of just exploding everything
that we had grown up
with about being female and the
limitations that that meant.
So the question that I
would love to ask you
is about your really
interesting statement,
that we made a mistake
by focusing exclusively
on gender in the 1970s.
No, by casting a discourse
entirely around gender,
as if you could only have
access to these ideas
if you were a woman.
So that's such a powerful issue
for us to be thinking about.
And I love the way you
suggested that it's
values that are really the
foundation of feminism.
I just wonder if
you could help us
think about this historically?
How clearly people did feel a
necessity to focus on gender
and to create women only
spaces and experiences.
And was that a
historical moment?
Well, actually, I'd
like to answer that
slightly differently,
because it actually
ties in with my points
in Institutional
Time about the
institutional failure
to transmit our
history, to transmit
the history, for example, of
this Feminist Art Movement.
And what that is present
in young people with today,
in Los Angeles, for example.
So Cal Arts where I brought
my Feminist Art program that
did Woman House, where
we did Woman House,
erased the history of
the Feminist Art program
from its institutional memory.
And in the 1990s,
some young students
discovered the archives of
the Feminist Art program
in the garbage
and retrieved them
and did a whole show
in a symposium called
The "F" Word, OK?
Now Cal Arts has recently
begun to acknowledge
Woman House and the
Feminist Art program,
but that was is only,
in my estimation,
because of the Getty-funded,
Pacific Standard Time,
$14 million initiative
which documented
and celebrated Southern
California art from 1945
to 1980.
And one of the projects
that they funded
was a two-volume book
about the Woman's Building
and the Feminist Art Movement.
So it would have been a little
embarrassing for Cal Art
to say, oh, leave us out of
that book, will you please?
OK, so there's that.
And as a result of that,
young women students still
are having to do it themselves.
So there's a young woman
artist in Los Angeles named
Audrey Chan, she's Asian,
she's a performance artist.
And she was talking
about actually
what you just mentioned,
was the sort of aura
of the 1970s and my presence,
knit symbolic presence there,
even if I wasn't there.
And so in order to
have access to me,
she started performing as me.
And she did this
wonderful videotape
called, How I Became a
Feminist Artist Without Living
Through the '70s.
[LAUGHTER]
And now she's instituted an
intergenerational dialogue
with me that's going
to become a book.
But my point is, that they
have to do it all themselves,
because the institutions
are not doing it.
That art programs are
not teaching young women
about the history of the
Feminist Art Movement.
They're not teaching
them about the legacy
of the '70s Women's Building.
In fact, there's a group
of young women artists
who are trying to rent the
Spring Street Women's Building
and set up another women's
collective in there,
because the need is still there
and the institutions are still
failing, is my answer.
Hi, who are you?
Hi.
I'm a painter from Iran.
I live and work in Tehran.
I'm here for a short time.
I'm lucky to be here.
My heart is pumping fast.
You inspired me and many
other artists in my country
and around the world.
I am self-taught.
I haven't MFA, or I haven't
been in any Academy at all,
but I'm known, I think, as an
anti-war painter in my country
and around.
I like to use this
chance here to ask you,
what would you tell me
to help my career there?
Mm.
I was in this show some years
ago with a young Iranian woman
artist.
It was an international show
in the Bay Area in California.
And she brought the
whole audience to tears
because she talked about
what she had to do in order
to get her work out of Iran.
Her husband was an engineer
from a prominent family,
and they had to
sneak her work out
through Federal
Express at midnight,
because she was dealing with
the subject of the harem.
Actually, she told us all--
I didn't know this.
You couldn't have whole
bananas or whole zucchinis
or anything in the harem.
Did you know that?
They'd always slice them up.
But anyway, I mean,
it was the first time,
when she was speaking
about her work,
it was the first
time she had ever
tried to traverse from
the private life she
had to live there--
Same story.
--to the public.
Yeah.
And she was shaking.
I-- I don't know how to--
I went and stood behind her
to try and give her courage.
I mean, that's all we can--
I could do is say you,
you know, here's my hand.
I don't know, because we have
to fight for even basic rights,
not with government, even with
our families and loved ones.
That's not only in Iran.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Believe me, when I was
doing The Birth Project
and I was working with
women in their homes,
they had to fight
with their loved ones
too, in order to even
get time to work.
Yes.
And I stayed 20 years in
my studio and just worked.
And I knew this work related to
war, no one wanted to see them.
When the government
came to buy some of them
for war and veterans
museum, I refused, because I
didn't want to be part of them.
I'm against them, you know?
And the thing that I think
I really doesn't had,
because we sanctioned
our government institutes
like museums, I never sent a
work to a museum in Tehran,
you know.
And how people think here about
this, they censored my book.
I had to publish my
book out of the country,
in Iraq, because I didn't want
them to get censored again.
Because for me, all of them
have meanings together.
This is a series about war, my
personal life with a veteran
and with others who
had endured mentally,
emotionally, physically,
even myself, during the war.
And after the revolution,
during all the hard time we had,
or the protests we had
in [? grieve ?] movement.
You know, it's very difficult.
Because now, new generations
after me, they're
brought up with media
and know so many other
things, you know.
I believe the generations
change every five years.
And as you said, the connections
and network is very important,
and we don't have it, because
we don't have access to--
All I can say is, in
this case, the way women
built networks of
support, I mean
women built networks of support
for not just since the 1970s
here, I mean, it's what Gerda
Lerner, the women's historian
talked about, women
building affinity groups.
I mean, you have to have
your own affinity groups.
You just have to have
your own affinity group,
however you can
put that together.
I think we'll have to let other
people-- there's a long line--
ask their questions.
OK, thank you very much.
Who are you?
I want to give a name
to that previous artist.
She did not give her name.
So that is Minu Emami.
So let's look out
for her, and let's
make our own affirmative
network for her.
I'm an art historian.
I've met Judy Chicago
briefly in the past,
my name is Caroline Jones.
And I teach feminist
art whenever I can.
And my question is to
surface a little bit
of a paradox,
because we've heard
a lot about the failures
of academic feminism,
of the Academy in
general, of art teaching.
And yet, these wonderful
papers are here
in the heart of the Academy.
So the question is,
what are we to do?
Should the Academy do its best
to make history and pedagogical
objects, teaching objects,
books about popular feminism?
Or should we also continue to
do the work of theory, which
is also what the Academy does?
So you know, I
leave that question.
I don't need to stand here.
But to me, in a way,
it's a beautiful paradox
that we're left with here at
Radcliffe, which has always
been two kinds of
institutions-- it's always
been embedded in a large
university educational machine.
And it's also been a community.
So I'd leave those as
provocative questions
about the future of your papers
and the historians of the same.
I would like to respond
with a quote from Bell Hooks
that I use in Institutional
Time, in the chapter,
So What's the Answer?
"The classroom, with
all its limitations,
remains a location
of possibility.
In that field of possibility,
we have the opportunity
to labor for freedom, to demand
of ourselves and our comrades
an openness of mind and heart
that allows us to face reality,
even as we collectively imagine
ways to move beyond boundaries
to transgress.
This is education as the
practice of freedom."
Go, Bell.
OK.
Could I also respond?
I think it's important--
feminist theory
is-- there is always a
place for feminist theory.
I think it's also important
to have popular feminist--
histories of popular
feminism, because translation
has to happen.
Feminist ideas
need to circulate.
They're not only
consumed in a classroom.
And so the translation
of those ideas
into a lot of different
medium, and as those
mediums interact
with audiences who
aren't in women's
studies classes,
those ideas are contagious.
They can get people thinking.
That sort of transmission
of feminist theory
broadly is a story that
we need to tell, as well.
So I think it's
important to make place
for both of these, at least
these two kinds of feminism--
there's so many kinds,
so many kinds of ways
to apply feminist theory.
And I think in the Academy
we've tended to privilege
certain ones over others.
So yeah, my book was
about trying to broaden
that out a little more.
Hello, I'm Edie Shimel.
I'm actually the Youth
Programs Coordinator
at the Peabody Essex Museum.
Oh, I'm the Youth Programs
Coordinator at the Peabody
Essex Museum and I've been in
museum education for a while.
I was at the ICA before working
with the subsidized programs,
like teen programs, things like
that for after school groups
who don't necessarily have
access to much of anything.
Which is, I think,
what you were talking
about when the
discourse is now sort
of the general, social
injustice that feminists art
history and just all of that
kind of works its way into.
And my question is, how, as
someone who's working with
younger populations who really,
some of them are getting
their first sort of art
experiences through the museum
and through me, how does
one, I don't know if you know
the ans-- how do you
sort of distill--
like when is it
time to sort of pull
the nuances of social injustice
and historic injustice
and women's injustice within
this sort of community arts
context?
Because I think that
there's a lot of room
for more depth within
our collection,
but I just don't really know
anybody that's doing that.
And I didn't know if you knew
anybody or had never thought
about that?
I could go into any community
and using my pedagogy,
all the issues of
social injustice,
gender injustice,
abuse, whatever
it is they're experiencing
would come out.
Because what I have always
practiced and am advocating
in Institutional Time is a
content-based artist education,
where people start
with who they are
and a circle pedagogy,
where people open up
about who they are.
And before two or three
weeks has gone by,
they will have revealed
all the injustice
that they have experienced.
They will be in it
before they-- they
don't have to
intellectualize it.
You don't have to introduce
it, because they've already
experienced it.
You just have to help them
say and what they have to say.
Thanks.
Where's Constance?
Constance, where are you?
Constance Gee is right here.
She spent a lot of her
years as an art educator.
Donald and I first
met her when she
was the First Lady
of Vanderbilt.
And she's the one who
guided us, guided me
into an understanding of some
of the changes that are taking
place in K through 12 curriculum
around gender, social justice,
race, ethnicity,
sexual orientation.
I mean there's a huge--
you should read a book
by Marilyn Stewart called
Rethinking Curriculum in Art.
That's another
thing I talk about
in Institutional Time is that,
you know, just like nobody paid
attention to the China
painters or the needle workers
because they were women when I
was trying to bring that over,
a lot of the work has been
done in K through 12 art
education has not been looked at
in the university, because art
education in K through 12 is
generally dominated by women.
But they've been doing
an enormous amount
of work in all these areas.
Rethinking Curriculum in Art.
Yes.
Hi, my name Beth
[? Ankus. ?] I'm an artist.
I went to a local
women's college.
And I was wondering
your perspective
on art at all women's colleges.
How studio art should
be taught there?
Because from what
I've seen, it's
being minimized quite a
bit in favor of biology
and certain other things.
And I just wanted
your thoughts on what
art studio and art
history should be
like at all women's colleges?
I actually talk about it
in Institutional Time.
I was invited to go to
Moore College of Art.
Actually, I was invited twice.
The first time I went
there was in the 1980s.
Moore was the only art
college for women in America.
The first time I went
there was in the '80s.
And it was an all-male faculty.
That was definitely not how
it should've been taught.
But anyway, in fact,
it was a good thing
that the elevator door closed
rather rapidly, because one
of the male faculty followed
Donald and me to the elevator
and said, I wish I were a
woman, a black, or a chimpanzee
so I could get
affirmative action.
The elevator door
closed, or Donald would
have punched him in the face.
But anyway, I went
back because there
was a wonderful woman
named Happy Fernandez who
took it over, was trying to
decolonize it and change it.
Anyway, so she asked
me to come back.
And I mean, I was shocked
to discover-- well,
first of all, the young
women were very puzzled
by their art education.
I did critiques with
several of them,
I mean with several classes,
juniors and seniors.
They were very puzzled,
because for the first two
years of their
art education they
talked about nothing
but form and materials.
And then in junior
year they were suddenly
supposed to have
personal content.
And they had no idea how
to access their own subject
matter, which isn't that
hard to do, actually.
It was frustrating.
So, I mean, we
talked about content,
which was the first
time they'd ever
had the opportunity
to talk about what
their real intentions
were in art.
Because not only
is art education--
is there de-skilling going
on in studio art education,
there's almost no
discussion of content.
And although it's a
generalization to say this,
I've worked with literally
hundreds and hundreds of women.
And by and large, women approach
art making from a content base
more than men.
And the way art school is set
up, that is not addressed.
So they are not helped, in terms
of developing their own voices.
And the other thing at
Moore that I was shocked at
was that there were
almost no women's studies
courses, no feminist theory.
I mean, it was--
so, I mean, I have
seen examples of what
not to do more often than I've
seen examples of what to do.
But certainly at
a women's college,
women ought to have
the opportunity
to learn their history, to
see what women before them
thought, taught, and created.
It ought to be integrated
into the curriculum.
And they ought to be helped
to find their own voices.
That help?
Oh, yeah.
Do you agree?
Definitely.
Thanks, OK.
How about that?
Hi.
I'm Colleen [? Emmerman. ?]
So I actually
work here across the river
at the Business School
on a gender
initiative over there.
So I have a very kind
of general question
that I would love to hear
either or both of you speak to,
and it's going back to this
term from the title Popular
Feminism.
So it seems to me like a
lot of what you both have
been in this dialogue,
talking about
is sort of the long
history of feminism
as a social movement from
the people exerting pressure
on institutions and
still doing that.
But it seems to me another
way to think about this term,
or another thing that's
conjured in my mind,
seems to me today that something
like feminism or something
called feminism has
a kind of popularity
and a kind of currency and a
kind of mainstream presence
that it's not had before,
certainly not in my lifetime.
And so I'm just really curious,
sort of, what your assessment
or sense of that is?
And whether it's something
that leaves you hopeful or not,
sort of, what your
take on that is?
The historian's question?
Yeah.
Well, so much of '70s
feminism succeeded.
It was kind of a way--
so much changed as a result
of the wave of activism
in the '60s through
the mid-'80s.
And one of the successes
of the movement
is that it's available as
a commodity in the market,
the cultural marketplace.
We can consume feminism in
magazines, Oprah, Ellen, Girls,
whatever list of things
you might want to pop onto
to say, yeah, look at--
there is some conversation
about feminism going on.
That is not the same beast
that Judy's talking about.
A lot is lost in
the translation.
But I do think it's important
to notice that it is there
as we can see feminist themed
cultural products everywhere
we go.
And I chalk that
up as a positive.
It might not be the feminism
you particularly want to see,
you might be able to list
all the failures of it.
But the fact it's there means
that people coming of age
are interacting with
it in a way that, I
know, it wasn't as available
when I was growing up
in the '70s, certainly not
when Judy was living her life.
So I think that's a success,
even if it's paradoxical.
Thank you, all.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]